good afternoon
good afternoon colleagues and just
before we start the meeting i'm just
going to head over to monitoring
a few words of advice
as this is the first time we've used
this area as a council chamber i'm going
to outline the fire safety issues we are
not expecting a fire alarm so shoot one
sound you should proceed to the fire
exits
there are two exits one in each side of
the room and both may be used if the
alarm sounds please make your way
through these exits
when you leave the building you should
make your way to the fire ascending
point up the steps in the front car park
for this meeting
will be the designated firewall
i'm also going to
read out some instructions about the use
of the microphones
again engage the services of a sound and
then a sound engineer who has supplied
the mics
to work well so that everyone in one can
hear the mics must be used properly
the streaming is also very dependent
upon the copy use of the microphones
please for members remember to
raise a hand if you wish to speak so
turn the engineer
microphones for you
please speak directly into the
microphones they are designed for the
speaker to be very close and do not work
if the speaker is not
close the chair requests that you do not
stand when speaking today so that you
can get as close to the microphone as
possible
the engineer will switch off the
microphone when you
finish speaking
and please don't wash your papers
[Music]
do we have any nominations council dale
thank you chair
is that working okay yeah brilliant um i
have a great pleasure in proposing
councillor diana ruff for the role of
chair of council
during her working career diana worked
in administration including within
schools
before retiring and i know from many
conversations with her that she has a
real passion for education and ensuring
that children and young people get the
best possible start in life
diana was a parish councillor for
several years
and many of which she served with
distinction as the chair of wingwood
parish council she was elected to
northeast irish district council in 2019
and has served on the richmond homes
board
as well as as chair of planning now i
think we all know that planning is not
an easy meeting to chair
but diana's calm and level-headed
approach has gone a long way to
professionalising the planning committee
and i think the committee as a whole has
come on leaps and bounds in the past few
years
i think hopefully i speak for all of us
when i say that she's well respected
across the board and i'm sure she'll
bring her firm but fair approach
to full council meetings
but i think what amazes me most about
diana is her amazing powers of foresight
and the lengths you'll go to
when committed to something
i think we know from recent past chairs
that they've not always enjoyed the best
of luck
particularly as far as their limbs are
concerned
some have even gone as far as to say
that their role is curse with the number
of broken lace we've had
among recent past
past chairs
diana recognizing this and wanting to
get ahead of the game
so she has a clear year as chair with
all of the limbs intact opted to have
major knee surgery immediately before
this meeting
amazing dedication to the role diana
in all seriousness though it's brilliant
that you've managed to make it here
today and i'm sure everyone will join me
in wishing you a very speedy recovery so
you can hit the ground running for your
civic year
i also wish you the best of luck for
your year as chair although i'm quite
sure you won't need it and you'll do a
fantastic job in representing the
district chairing these meetings and
raising money for your chosen charity so
all that's left for me to say that chair
is break a leg
thank you council dale do we have a
secondary council
chair
um thank you chair i'm delighted to step
in with councillor as the proposed chair
of this council for the coming year i've
known councillor for quite a few years
now initially as a committed community
champion and campaigner who prior to
being elected to the district council i
think spent longer at planning committee
meetings eloquently representing
residents than many committee members or
councillors
since then i've been able to watch and
learn from counsellor as a dedicated
district councillor
as a ward member who seems to know
almost everyone in a quite large ward on
first name terms and as a firm but very
fair planning committee chair where she
brought a calm and reasonable stance to
what can often understandably be
emotional meetings as we head towards a
big year next year i'm sure that would
be crucial experience and sharing in
this chamber
i'll let councillor ruff speak more
about her chosen charity if successful
but i know it's one she's incredibly
passionate about and so she's eager to
raise funds but also crucially awareness
and support for them over the coming
year if she can
everything she's done so far as a
district councillor highlights to me
that she would do a fantastic job as
chair
sporting councillors would be her
husband jeff for her consort
jeff and diana have been married for
over 30 years whilst jeff is retired now
i understand it in his i.t focused
career he was known as the man who could
fix the impossible which combined his
hobbies
combined with these hobbies of steam
power classic cars and the outdoors
should stand in good stead as consort
hopefully not having to fix the church
travel to events
i know that family is rightly really
important to both jeff and diana and
theirs is very close-knit and i know
that they're ready to support her over
the year ahead so i hope you'll all
support councillor today as chair just
on a final note home the sand she's an
excellent baker they may also be the
promise of faith sales thank
you because stupid are there any other
nominations
it has been moved and seconded that
councillor diana ruff
the elected chair of the council for the
2022
municipal year
all those in favor
anyone against
any abstentions
is carried congratulations counter off i
will now invest you with a chain of
office
[Music]
thank you colleagues i'd like to take
this opportunity to thank you all for
this honor and privilege
to be elected as chair of the council
for the coming year
i can assure you that i will do that all
i can which we pay you all by serving
the council and our communities of
northeast denver to the best of my
ability
i am keen to build on the hard work of
all the previous chairs and like them
intend to be a friendly place we've seen
in our town and villages
to help show case the council and the
services we have
my chosen charity is saffron it's quite
close to my heart my father served in
the whole neighborhood for many years
except the stairs for soldiers sailors
airmen and family association
most of you will have heard of them but
i'm not sure how many women know that
they were the original forces charity
started decades ago
suffer works alongside british legion
and help for heroes who seem to get more
than their fair share of publicity
with this in mind i've chosen chef at
saffron so that i can help showcase and
raise awareness of the great work that
they do
sakura has helped many families across
our own district and will continue to do
so
so i hope that you will help support me
during the year to raise not only their
awareness but some funds for this wealth
supported charity
once again thank you for this honor now
i think we should move on to question
three
martin has been an excellent chair but
then we would have expected nothing less
he would be a hard act to follow both in
which he has kept our council meetings
running smoothly and fairly
and for his quiet staggering fundraising
work on behalf of our state hospice
however there is saying that behind
every successful man there is a good
woman
martin has been very lucky in fact he
has had two good women
first is constant g that has put up with
a horrendous year so well done g
and secondly joe bradley the chairs pa
she was joe has worked tirelessly behind
the scenes so well done both ladies
on this occasion we didn't want to pass
the day without benji martin with some
mementos relating to your great chilling
of office
i'm not sure how this is going to happen
safely and precious
um but hopefully i can present you with
a first of
two
[Music]
so with that in mind i'd like to present
you with the first volume
and
your council medallion
[Music]
[Music]
thank you chair so may i have been the
first to congratulate you councillor
from your election as 36th chair of
northeast derbyshire district council
gene and i thoroughly enjoyed our turn
in office
and i'm grateful to the council for
allowing me to represent the authority
it has been a privilege
throughout the year we have carried out
numerous engagements
ranging from welcoming returning
residents to their refurbished written
home
to opening show properties on a
development in the district
we attended several civic services
across derbyshire
the memorial service for prince philip
the high sheriff's legal service
the jubilee commemoration at derby
cathedral
and sadly the funeral of a former
council consult
there was recognition of others when
attending emergency services day
the voluntary sector awards
and many events linked to the armed
forces covenant
the highlight of the year was our visit
to darmstadt
it was great to revisit the area
and use the time to promote meaningful
links between our communities
it was an opportunity to ignite a
reimagining of the partnership between
us
the flames of friendship need to be
found
even more so within the not too distant
future
as we approach a significant landmark in
our cooperation
our chosen appeal has been ashgate
hospice
the work of the hospice for patients
with cancer and their families is known
to all of us
they make a significant difference for
so many people
to raise funds g and i have undertaken a
variety of events
ranging from an elvis night to a pinky
blinders evening
you may have enjoyed our gin and cheese
night
or purchased a bottle of gin
you could be one of those who shared a
splendid visit to tissington hall
or came along to the concert at
chatsworth
we have been fortunate to have enjoyed
the support of organizations and various
individuals
i thank all those who have kindly helped
us along the way
a special thanks all for the council
staff who have aided us
joe bradley
kevin mcgrogan
and dave eagley
along with moraine shaw of rickwood
homes
i also wish to express sincere
appreciation
to councillor bentley strafford
stevenson
and councillor jane barry
who have been amazing stalwarts of our
fundraising efforts
gene and i visited the hospice this
morning
to share with them the news that our
civic appeal
stands at
79
500 pounds
this amount is testimony to the
generosity of the people of north east
derbyshire
the hard work of a few
and the backing of family and friends
gene has been a truly outstanding
consort
she has been a tower of strength
throughout our civic year and the
epitome
of grace and dignity
she remains
my raison d'etre
thank you gene
i am sure you will have a rewarding year
gene and i have found it to be an
experience
we will never forget
thank you
before we move on is there anyone that
would like to say
and i've got a load of hands-on
counselor barry
council hancock and councilman thank you
i think he's doing an absolutely
fabulous job
you know i mean the amount of hours of
work that both himself and junior put
into this has been absolutely amazing
and
i'm really really proud of you and it's
difficult to say that since you're a
tour
but i'll say it because it's true
and i think
you know myself and some of my
colleagues supported you through that
and we all think you've done an amazing
job
and and it's going to be a difficult set
of shoes to fill on the frame and but
thank you very much for doing it thank
you for getting that money all together
for the people of northeast english
and the charity that it's going to go to
so thanks again martin
thank you chair
um i'd just like to record what james
said it's it's a tremendous amount and i
think also in the chamber um the role of
chair is is impartial and without doubt
i think you have you have been the most
impartial probably best chair of the
years i've sat on this council and uh
thank you very much
people and practical close friends
before i was proud of the electors award
member for barlow holmes
council of fact i asked my wife and i to
join the support committee back in the
early 2021 for the civic year so i've
seen firsthand the blood sweat and tears
that he has put in to make this year's
such a success both in terms of his
fundraising efforts and the civic duties
of all entails all done in his own
manner and trauma
council attack has taken on the role as
civic chairman with professionalism
energy seriousness commitment and a
great deal of expense and profound
respect for the position and the role
the chair affords
this civic year has been full-on
schedule of events catering for all
interests and i'm sure you all agree the
amount he has raised is a truly
phenomenal effort and a real testament
to council attack his time as chair of
this cancer
and will have a meaningful impact on the
great work ashgate hospice does the
local community
i'm sure we all have personal experience
with the hospice
friends or friends of friends and this
warmth and respect for what actually
hospice does has been evidenced in the
great support for council factor
throughout his time in others from
members on all sides of this council as
well as within the local community
with
[Music]
i don't know of a single individual
within the wider derbyshire region who
has done more for the people of not just
northeast africa and chesterfield but
further afield across derbyshire and
nationally
he currently supports and dedicates his
time voluntarily to over 50
organizations with interest ranging from
the arts the armed forces community the
deaf community which i'm sure you all
know is close to council of pakistan
the law in his role as the justice of
the police and in his efforts to support
chesterfield football but to make just a
few
the dedication and sense of duty should
serve as an inspiration to all
other personal notes from me and my wife
i'd just like to thank you counselor for
all you do for our communities without
you many things would just not get done
and i know of all the stresses and
issues you have sufficiently sometimes
never fail to affect your sense of duty
so congratulations on your savior and
i'd like to say enjoy some time on but
knowing how many of the commitments you
already have and what you're recently
[Music]
um i don't think there's much more i can
say that that hasn't already been said
really but i did ask joe um this morning
just to give me a quick top top of the
number of events that were both posted
and attended i think it was over 50
events attended on behalf of the
district and well over 30 events
run yourself uh
so an absolutely amazing achievement i
think there's only one word
um and i think that it's not just that
the role of chair is yes it's about
raising vital funds for local charities
and
and representing the district but
actually being a fantastic advocate for
this council and i think that you
doubtless have helped afford bright new
relationships with lots of organizations
both within and outside of which you're
so vital to them as an
all i organization say is that youtube
thank you congratulations on a fantastic
fantastic achievement uh yeah and as
thank you for that
enjoy your
your your time off uh
the council um i just wanted to sort of
add a brief comment to all of the others
and just echo what everybody else has
said it's a phenomenal achievement
raised 79 500 pounds for ashgate and
hospice it was really was
astonishing and a very very worthy
charity um as we all know um i just
wanted to commend um
on his ability a unique ability to
extract extract cash and flavors
out of people
there were days i have to say that i
felt like i've contributed half of his
uh grandson
um but there really was an astonishing
i followed with interest all the
activity that he did you
thank you
if there are no further comments we move
on to item 4 apologies for absence
yes sure
yes we have apologies from councillor
ridgeway councilman lilly uh councillor
lacey and councillor reader
thank you
ready
i've seen five declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
interest and or other interests not
already on their register of interest
in any item on the agenda and withdraw
from the meeting at the appropriate time
do any members have any interests to
declare
[Music]
uh
[Music]
minutes of the last meeting we now have
the minutes of the meeting held on
tuesday the 25th of april 2022
are we happy that they are a correct
record and if so we set a member
is there a second one
[Music]
all those in favor
any gains
any extensions
promotion has been carried
for this the next item we're going to
simply be called vote by a show of hands
item seven election of the vice chair of
the
thank
council
for always having just selected me as
your chair this is now time for us to
elect the vice chair for the year do we
have any nominations
having said all we've just said about
that rest here i'd like to propose uh
motion has been carried
item 8 composition of the cabinet
we will all have received as part of the
updated agenda fact the paper from the
leaders setting out the composition of
the cabinet
as you can see very little has changed
on that basis i suggest that we vote for
the information only onto our next item
do we agree to note the information
we can do
[Music]
everyone's happy with psyche thank you
thank you members item nine is scheme of
delegation
item nine is our scheme of dedication
for the year i would like the assistant
director of governments to run through
it and then give you the opportunity to
ask for
clarification or to speak on it
thank you chairman
each year at the annual meeting
members are required by the constitution
to approve the delegation scheme
this year this coincides with the
interim senior management structure
changes
accordingly i have taken this into
account in the proposed delegation
scheme
there are no new delegations it is
simply a redistribution of existing
delegations
standards committee will review the
delegation scheme and make
recommendations as to any changes as
part of its constitutional review
program in the next corporate year in
relation to paragraph 1.4 there is a
proposed change to existing delegations
to refer to shared services rather than
the strategic allowance alliance which
is one kind of shared service
the recommendation on page 15 is to
approve the scheme but don't be happy to
try to answer any questions
your hands but you will start it thank
you
thank you emotions being carried
item 10 is the appointment of chairs and
buy shares that brings us to this
appointment with the chairs and vice
chairs for the year
having your updated pattern nominations
from the majority group
if there are no other nominations i
suggest we put them to the vote
games
[Music]
nomination forward
for this year but
i think this time next year things might
be a bit
[Music]
thank you different um i'll say this
every year but i truly believe the
scrutiny committees cheers and vice
chairs need to be opposition counselors
i think it's very strange
that we have the
group that's leading the council also
cheering committees that's supposed to
be scrutinizing the council's behavior
and policies and decisions
and that's the way i was here
thank you for your comments any other
[Music]
just
[Music]
appointments to committees and advisory
groups
appointments to committees and advisory
groups as i understand if the group
leaders have been consulted on this and
they're still nominations
are there any last minute changes
required
[Music]
any extensions
no space
and three motions will be carried
item 12 appointment to the outside
bodies
12 members is the proposed night
appointment for council to outside
bodies there are in your updated gender
pack as you will have seen there is a
vacancy on the homegate joby and joan
club following the subpassing of
councillor ann holmes i would like to
ask councilman eisenbach on behalf of
the labor group if he wishes to nominate
a member to the vacancy
yeah i'd like to move
councillor uh jones please
thank you thank you is there a second
week
thank you
sorry just one or two other
[Music]
um
i think it was a
slightly older version that went out and
realized that there were a few errors in
there so the community safety
partnerships
uh it's currently down as you know
council and parliament should be
uh for caroline reddick to reflect the
uh the changing portfolios
uh ridgeway sports and social club as i
understand it from council renek it
should only be wanderer
uh
[Music]
um
[Music]
just have quickshow plans that
everyone's happy with those changes
[Music]
thank you
item 13
operation emergency rules and thresholds
certain
decisions this is the final of the
procedural items on today's agenda
basically under our procedural rules
council is required to set the
thresholds for key decisions at its
meetings
you ask to consider a report of the
leader of the council in relation to the
urgency rules
and to set the thresholds for key
decisions i call on the leader to
explain
thank you
oh yeah this report deals with two
constitutional issues that we're
required to consider on an annual basis
so the first relates to where key
decisions have been made by cabinet
without compliance the usual uh
requirements of 28 days uh publication
and notice this is usually when a
decision is too urgent um to wait we
have to make it open
um the report explains that
what a key decision is effectively and
the constitution also provides an
alternative system
of notification where that 28 days
notice can't be given and effectively
the process is that the chair of the
relevant scrutiny
committee
would be
there would be a discussion with them
and they would obviously enable the
report to be considered um however i
have pleasure in explaining that that
we we haven't had to use that system at
all this year so effectively not being
used and therefore
it's just a report on that fact the
other aspect is the key decision
financial limits obviously the financial
limit is is how the council determines
the expenditure of savings uh and how
significant they are
and therefore what's the key decision
for cabinet the current levels are 100
000 pounds for revenue and 250 000
pounds for
uh capital and it's proposed that these
uh these rates remain um as they ask for
coming in so on that note i'm happy to
move the recommendations on
on page 28.
thank you
is there a second though
go to show of hands
all those in favor
aye
any extensions
emotions being carried
item 14 i'm just going to hand this over
to
the video
to explain the
[Music]
uh
[Music]
bring that back to the next
full council meeting
[Music]
urgent business i have no urgent
business at this stage
so i do declare this meeting closed
however i do ask you to stay in your
places for our lives
[Music]
yes
[Music]
okay
unfortunately have to go through
apologies for absence
[Music]
uh apologies as uh given up the first
meeting members
thank you
item two declarations of interest
members are requested to declare the
existence and nature of any disposable
puny interests
and or other interests not already on
their registered interests
and any items on the agenda and
withdrawal from the meeting at the
appropriate time
are there
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
but
it's the same trust
you also trustees
in your own right
yes
not well national women in my work
[Music]
capital
[Music]
thank you
are there any other declarations of
interest
okay moving on to item three upgraded
football pitch and falls installations
of charlotte park
thank you chair
uh i just wanted to explain a little of
the background as you can see this
relates to ownership of some land in the
charlotte park project the owner is a
charity with a full charity commission
scheme the scheme names the council as
trustee
this means the council has me has to
meet and deal with this separately from
the rest of its business
the charity commission requires the
trustees deal with the charitable
business only in a specific meeting for
that purpose
and might send the background to this
now hand over to cancer power for me
thank you mr sternberg
uh members didn't realize because i
didn't that we were as accountable
um
of the um
sort of getting by
across the days war miners welfare
recreation grant charity
by virtue of the church commission order
dated september 1988.
this is subdivided into two other
charities uh one of which is responsible
for the recreation grant
what we are seeking to do today and what
i will propose
is that as part of the huge shelley prop
development which you are all aware of
we want to replace some other decrepit
football pitch with a brand new spanking
shining 3g pitch um it's from the
existing site so it's not moving anymore
this is going to be better
and at the same time
as part of it we want to install a
footpath
and cycle path
which will probably be a measured mile
um to be installed on the uh on the
trustland
um so uh if anyone has any questions
but if not i will make my
recommendations
[Music]
thank you chair um i'm just actually
clarifying on the legal technicalities
here um because obviously only in
principle it's something that support um
obviously if we're sitting here as
trustees we have to make our decisions
in the legal interests of the charity
not in the legal interest of the council
and we were putting um the actual legal
responsibility to maintain that footpath
i can start that off you are quite right
you are making the decision in the best
interest of the charity and in relation
to the maintenance of car blog i'd have
to hand over to the director
[Music]
[Music]
the maintenance of the 3g football pitch
as well
there isn't any anticipated maintenance
costs or liabilities
yeah thank you thank you
are we all happy to accept this circle
because we have a show of
hands thank you any against
any abstentions
the report has been accepted thank you
finally chair surgeon business just go
home and put my leg up
[Laughter]
thank you all very much for my first
meeting thank you
you